today I'm going to tell you about one of
my favorite results Bell's Theorem that
answers the EPR paradox but instead of
just proving the thing here I've decided
to push that back to next video and
instead just tell you the results and
explain what it actually means that's
because this is one of the most
misunderstood theorems of science that I
know of I've heard it claimed by so many
sources from popular books to lecturers
to serious research papers that Bell's
Theorem proves quantum mechanics is
right let's see if that's true
we've already seen that quantum
mechanics has a few disturbing aspects
I'd argue that a lot of that comes down
to one statement in quantum mechanics
the superposition principle that is that
if we have a particle that could be in
several states at a certain time and we
can't tell which one it's actually in
then it's in all those states at once
that means that while we have our backs
turned things act way differently to how
they act when we're looking but do we
actually need to believe that I mean we
can never by definition actually catch
the objects in the act the EPR paradox
tried to prove that superposition is
wrong I won't go through the EPR
argument in detail again because you can
just watch that video once more if you
need a refresher but remember for the
EPR video we had two entangled objects
and we knew one was red and the other
way but we didn't know which was which
quantum mechanics insists that all
possible things happen so each particle
is both red and white but if we open one
box and the object is white then when we
open the other we must have the red
object the only way is if somehow or
other the particles can talk to each
other
we'll call any theory where entangled
particles are able to communicate while
they're separated like this a theory
with talking particles the EPR argument
showed that if a theory has talking
particles then those messages are going
faster than light so what does this mean
if Einstein and the majority of
physicists at the time were right and
nothing can ever go faster than light
then EPR tells us that all theories with
talking particles are wrong that include
it's quantum mechanics if nothing can
truly go faster than light then how to
explain the fact that entangled
particles always have opposite colors to
each other they can't talk to each other
while they're separated as EPR shows so
they must decide which colors to be
while they're still together that means
that instead of acting all crazy and
going into super positions while they're
behind our backs they instead act pretty
normal with just one color so you see if
nothing can go faster than the speed of
light not only is quantum mechanics done
for we can go back to believing that the
world isn't doing crazy things while
we're not looking I II if particles
can't talk faster than light then
superposition is wrong what about the
other possibility what if entangled
particles do talk faster and light to
each other
this is where lots of people get it
wrong so I urge you to be careful if
entangled particles do talk fast and
light to each other that doesn't
necessarily imply that superposition is
right that would be like saying if an
animal is a raven it is black means that
if an animal isn't a raven then it's not
black that clearly isn't true if an
animal isn't a raven or you can say is
that it's not a raven
you can't infer anything about its color
in the same way if particles can talk
faster than light then all you can say
is they do talk faster than light so
finally we get to the point
what is Bell's Theorem Bell came up with
an experiment that would give different
results in a world where particles can
talk faster than light and in one where
they couldn't disco people really
excited because this was a chance to
disprove quantum mechanics 15 years
later people finally came up with the
technology to do the experiment their
result particles do actually talk faster
than light quantum mechanics survived
but like I said before this doesn't
prove that quantum mechanics is right
only that it isn't wrong in this
particular way this brings up a lot of
questions firstly what about relativity
remember that I told you that the
assumption in relativity is that nothing
can go faster than the speed of light
but apparently that's not true
I don't know enough relativity to teach
it to you but in relativity if it's
possible for Alice to send Bob a message
faster than light then all kinds of
crazy stuff can happen for example to
some people it will look like Bob gets
Alice's message before she sends it it's
even possible for him to reply before
she sends it but then what if she
decides not to send her original message
after all this is an awful logical mess
so what's the solution
does this assay that they have come up
with it they claim that it's impossible
to manipulate our entangled talking
particles to send the messages we want
this is called the no communication
theorem I don't know if we should just
trust them though so we'll have a closer
look at it a little later
another question is that sure this
experiment doesn't prove that
superposition is true but is it really
possible to explain all the weird
experiments we've been talking about
without it turns out it might be there
is at least one very promising
alternative to quantum mechanics that
does have talking particles so it's not
ruled out but doesn't have superposition
it's called bohmian mechanics and I
might make a video about it because it's
pretty amazing so that's the end of this
video but if you want to see how Bell's
Theorem proves that particles can talk
fast and light then I will be putting up
videos about that very soon hopefully
there'll be one to explain something
called spin and then the actual proof
itself if you don't know too much about
spin you should probably watch that one
first